[Music]
the southern nevada health district
working to make improvements to the
largest vaccination site in clark county
thanks for joining us at six
i'm brian loftis hi there brian and i'm
denise valdez
60 000 vaccines have already been
administered in clark county
so far and 14 000 of those at cashman
center
joe moller is there live tonight with
more on the expected temporary closure
though of that site
joe brian denise a few thousand doses
are administered here at cashman center
every single day i'll give you a live
look they closed their doors here a
couple hours ago but they set up some
fences out here for the line
and earlier today it was a very busy
there's a long line there
now something they say can be slowed
down for the appointments here is people
showing up
without appointments for the most part
it was
pretty easy sheila montez chavez brought
her family member to get the coven 19
vaccine we just kind of just let it go
an appointment is needed for the vaccine
but they still witness some people
showing up without one i mean there's
signs all over that says
you know appointments only but people
managed to get in line just
without an appointment they didn't get
very far they didn't get inside but
yeah they got in line the health
district has pushed for people to make
appointments as no walk-ups are allowed
i saw four people trying to get in line
without appointments and they said sorry
i'm glad they turned them away because i
heard the other day they were letting
anybody in
appointments can take roughly two hours
county officials say showing up without
an appointment slows down the process
for
everyone in line they are already trying
to speed up appointment times
and that is why the site will be closed
friday january 22nd through the weekend
for improvements so much traffic on the
website to
knock you out server not available all
those kinds of things
people say the appointment did take time
but that wasn't the hardest part
wayne smith said making his appointment
took hours he tried and had success
booking at an odd hour
i got in at 5 30 in the morning about
five days ago
now appointments will resume next week
you can make those on the health
district's website just
another tip like you heard smith there
saying just refreshing that page and
maybe book at an odd hour
reporting live here at cashman center
joe mullen 8 news now